and now ladies and gentlemen a man who
inspires one emotion in the hearts of
all other men
jealousy mr. Cary Grant
for the past two years I've appeared
here as a standing for a great actress
and a great lady tonight
I relinquish my job by happily saying
welcome back Ingrid Bergman
thank you for this most heartwarming
welcome and I've come to thank you the
belated thanks for the Oscar I got two
years ago and I wanted also to tell you
that at that moment in a way I was with
you due to the difference in time I
couldn't know about it of course so
early in the morning I had a telephone
call and I knew I had received the Oscar
and the day started it was very early in
the morning and it continued all day
long with television and newsreels and
the interviews and I thanked everybody
and I thanked everybody and I thank
everybody for this Oscar but I didn't
feel at all that I had received and I
went upstairs to my room in the hotel
Paris around 6:00 in the afternoon and I
was exhausted and went into the bathtub
and when I was lying there soaking still
feeling very little in came I didn't
some it's a portable radio and he said
my memory are talking about you and he
put the radio beside me and I couldn't
hear anything but a great applause and I
realized it was the transmission of the
of the show that had been given here 24
hours earlier and that they were giving
over the French radio and that Terry had
just said my name and I could hear the
applause and then Jerry's voice came
over the radio and he said dear Ingrid
if you can hear me I and all of us that
are here tonight we send you our love
wherever you are
and that's how I receive my Oscar in the
matter thank you again
now this is the moment you've been
waiting for the nominated are for the
Best Motion Picture of the year
Auntie Mame Warner Brothers Cat on a Hot
Tin Roof Aven productions
metro-goldwyn-mayer for Lawrence
Weingarten producer the Defiant ones
Stanley Kramer United Artists Stanley
Kramer producer givi Arthur freed
productions metro-goldwyn-mayer
Arthur freed producer separate tables
Clifton's productions United Artists
Harold picked producer well the winner
on again busy
for this honor I'm deeply grateful and
I'm doubly honored tonight in receiving
this presentation from this